sunny hostin who is one of the minor
characters over at the view
she
launched this argument just yesterday
she said that
elon musk's takeover of twitter
all it's really about
is about giving special treatment to
straight white men
on twitter it is predominantly
straight white men so when elon musk
says wow this is about free speech it
seems to me that it's about free speech
of straight white men and so let them
have it let them just go at it i enjoy
the block button on twitter
i think it has a real outsized influence
in in our world because politicians and
celebrities are on it
now i think this is no way to talk about
elon musk the most prominent
african-american in the world i mean
that's the first incoherence that we
have
i think the claim that she's making is
not true
white men not even straight white men
just white men in general are something
like what 30 of america
and significantly less than 30 of the
world population so i just don't think
it's and then how many of them are
straight i don't so
i i just don't think it's true that the
majority of twitter users are straight
white men
but let's say that they were
sunny hostin is act she's saying
the quiet part out loud i guess she's
saying i don't want straight white men
to be able to speak i want other groups
to be able to speak but i don't like
straight white men i i want to censor
straight white men i don't want them to
have a voice in our republic
oh well too bad lady
i say this as a straight swarthy man
a straight slightly tan man
we're going to speak we're going to
speak and i'm sorry that that bothers
you i'm sorry that you don't like
straight white men i'm sorry that you
want to ostracize us and kick us out of
society but we're not gonna do it we're
not i'm sorry we're not gonna go along
with that uh we're gonna speak we're
gonna say our mind and uh if you don't
like it that's to take it up with the
african americans new owner of twitter
because we're we're not going to we're
not going to put up with that kind of
stuff we're not we're not going to put
up with a new radical caste system it
foisted upon us by the the woke lunatics
that say that if you're
if you're not what if you're not lgbt
if you're
not a woman or any of the other 75
genders that aren't man
if you're
if you're not
a poc
then you're not allowed to speak we're
not going to do that i'm already
exercising my newfound freedom of speech
on twitter
i i just was sending out some test
tweets the other day to test the
algorithm i pointed out
various things such as transgenderism is
not a real category of being that's
obviously true i pointed out on twitter
that ivermectin is a wonder drug and
everyone called it a wonder drug until a
couple of years ago when it became a
political cudgel and the left denied
that
and then
then i pointed out
something that i think is obvious
i said the 2020 presidential election
was obviously rigged
good news is none of those tweets were
taken down they're not being suppressed
we're seeing lots of extra engagement
for conservatives i'm glad you liked
that clip now subscribe ring that bell
get all the notifications for the
michael knowles show you can go over to
spotify apple podcast wherever you get
your podcast type in the michael knowles
show knowles like beyonce know w l e s
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]